Nick throw it off
there it is all right why am I in this
shot why not dude
[Music]
in breaking news
another time that we're going to be on
time with some news sort of that's
pretty good two for two today don't
expect too much out there don't expect
too much former president Donald Trump
files to run in 2024 literally like
seven minutes ago but there's no point
in adding context to seven minutes ago
because you're probably seeing this a
month later but is that a surprise I
thought everyone knew he was gonna run
but he hadn't
announced it exactly oh first time wait
what about that speech he did like four
or five months ago in Texas or Arizona
and people were like oh he's running is
it because he he didn't officially
announce it but he he's been doing all
kinds of speeches but yeah he hasn't
announced anything and all like it
wasn't an official announcement well
there was a thing about campaign Finance
law where you can't say you're running
for president yet and not have like a
certain apparatus so like that's what
was speculated as to why he hasn't done
that yet but then now midterms are done
and so he's he's enough oh unless it
seems like everything he's always said
kind of hints at it to keep people
interested too yeah it's like all
teasers right he's a showman yeah
with all the like like maybe we're gonna
get into a war and all these crazy
things like I really wonder what will
happen if he does win
and then
all the friends that he's made friends
with Putin and all them like how they
gonna how is he gonna flip it
like that's really interesting to me
this is a perfect time to get some Joe
speculation Biden probably would just
continue on with what's been going on do
you ever feel a certain kinship with Joe
Biden because you both have the name Joe
we're both sleepy a couple of Joes we're
both sleepy I would I want to describe
you as being sleepy no I wouldn't either
I get sleepy of course yeah
I don't like that guy though not like
sleepy Joe no what's your what's your
take on what's going on because you
haven't been here from a sec to me it's
been so wild and all these things are
like coming from I mean like
I I'm still in disbelief that we might
go into World War III yeah you know what
the news that we found out about Poland
and [ __ ] in the missiles so I really
don't know how it's going to be handled
so let's say Trump doesn't go into
office right with Biden it's probably
just gonna be a continuation of what's
been going on proxy war in Ukraine and
just let's prolong it for as long as
possible do you think they let Biden run
again as like an 80 plus year old I hope
not because the party can't take them
out like if he's already the seating
president take a primary amount yeah it
happened it's happened before it
happened after the first term they would
just they would pull a sitting president
out they've done it before oh it's
happened to who Gerald Ford [ __ ]
he lost to Reagan So Reagan primaried
him out right and then um Reagan ran
successfully for president because I
didn't know that they had primaries for
sitting presidents who would they run
against Gerald Ford remember so Nixon
resigns right Gerald Ford steps in and
then Gerald Ford says I'm only gonna run
I'm only gonna be president for as long
as this term is and then I'm gonna sit
down and then he actually kind of
started to really Vibe he was like I'm
really vibing with the office I think
I'm kind of seeing the office like
molecularly and I'm like whoa I'm good
at the job and so then he decides to run
and then he gets primaried out by Reagan
and so that's what happened oh that
makes sense maybe there was a different
like relationship with like the people
to be like you know with a sitting
president who wasn't actually voted in
that way you know for sure was he a vice
president Jennifer was the vice
president yeah but then there was also
another vice president called Spiro
Agnew before Gerald Ford had to step
down because of corruption so then
Gerald Ford like came in to power that
way as the vice president and they
became President when Nixon resigned so
then Gerald Ford is the president and
then he's like I'm only going to be the
interim president and then he's like oh
psyches I want to be real president
that's like House of Cards yeah is this
similar to how uh Tom Brady became
quarterback
no well yes because Drew Bledsoe uh
stepped down as we all know
um and then um just because he sucked
ass in football and well he actually
went down because of an injury a
personal injury but then um yeah Tom
Brady stepped in and he lit it the [ __ ]
up but then but then Tom Brady was also
involved with FDX is why he should never
be able to throw a football
you should go down with the ship do
um when Reagan was President
I and like being a kid I always heard
people talking about that he was sucking
as a president was he good or bad well
depends on who you talk to yeah that's
what I don't know so like Reagan came
out with Reaganomics and then I trickled
my own economics was uh I think she
created the No Child Left Behind Act I
think so or like I might be wrong but
they say that that program messed up she
just dare she just dare was it there
okay maybe maybe I'm getting it mixed up
or was that Barbara Barbara Bush [ __ ] I
don't know No Child Left Behind was was
Bush W though oh really okay well it's
No Child Left Behind and it's like cool
dude like what does that mean even and
then that means you just push him up the
grades even if they don't pass
everything yeah still very much left
behind in the long game I read a lot of
this stuff I just don't remember it's
okay so if we have a Child Left Behind
pretty much Dara was created by Daryl
Gates maybe that's why he called it dare
no but no yeah created I'm sure but
during their presidency it was pushed by
like I think Bush's
um hw's wife or I don't know so do you
think it's gonna be so it's gonna be
Trump and DeSantis duking and out for
the Republicans it seems like it
DeSantis has a pretty good chance people
like to say this but then people love
Trump so like the difference is Trump
has such a strong support like around
him he's got merch he's got good merch
pull it out pull it out we got both we
got the Joe Biden merch that no one
recognizes but we still got it no one's
ever won it yeah
Nick throw it off
why not
if you think about like the last I mean
election right the the vote was pretty
much 50 50. the popular vote
so there's still a lot of supporters of
trump in the states dude there's 70
something million people who voted for
him yeah it's it's yeah that's wild it's
a real thing you still got to see Dave
Chappelle's monologue and SNL talks
about that too in a solution let's watch
it right now yeah sure
yeah let's watch it can we react yeah
let's react to it can't we keep hitting
the space bar and he basically just
talks about how uh Trump's the first
honest liar that uh honest liar calls
him an honest liar yeah talks about he's
like the City Trump comes out talks
about how the system is all rigged and
stuff like that and they're like well
and then Biden and you know Hillary
Clinton is like no it's not and the
prompter is like how do you know do you
have any evidence he's like yeah because
I use the system and that's when that's
what it's like oh [ __ ] this was the
honestly
well that was the thing about Trump too
is like he would say like everyone says
like you know you know we're in the
Middle East why are we in the Middle
East she's like we're gonna take the oil
is like we're gonna take the [ __ ] oil
and like
that's the first time my life like
George W would never have said that [ __ ]
we all know they were there for the oil
but George W's not he's like he's like
whatever what it's called oh voting yeah
votes
don't let people vote isn't that good
we're gonna spread democracy what is it
called by the way does anybody think
that bush won Florida in 2000 does
anybody really think that bush Wanted 2
000 because I sure do because I'm a
[ __ ] American hanging Chad's dude was
that what the exactly so so you know
that whole voter fraud [ __ ] right that
um the Republicans now are claiming that
the Democrats did the Democrats actually
called Bush on voter fraud during that
whole time do you remember in 2004 when
D bold voting machines got rolled out
yeah and John Kerry lost and the
Democrats were saying that the voting
machines were rigged yeah from diebold I
remember this yesterday it's so funny
how everyone has selective memory about
the gym how would you even question
elections like dude everyone questions
every [ __ ] election it's been ever
since I was a kid it's a great move it's
a great move yeah why wouldn't you
can't handle it I still wish Ross Perell
won that one Ross Peru like Ross Perot
with his big ears I liked it for the
memes it was a good meme time but it was
meantime it was meantime for sure I used
to see those in Mad Magazine well he
used to one he's like there's a great
sucking sound coming out of China he's
like they're they're pulling up a lot of
these manufacturing jobs and God damn
was he right about that I really wonder
what it would have happened like if he
became president because he was the only
sensible one yeah and he's another
billionaire so he'd probably be [ __ ]
too that's the best part that's the best
part I don't mean to be too cynical but
be cynical talk about it look yeah yeah
if you elected billionaire guess what
they're going to do hook up their
buddies that's what happens every
[ __ ] time but all you can hope is
that like Reaganomics some of the good
[ __ ] trickles out into your [ __ ] open
mouth
that's literally how praying for it
that's how I see politics though right
the way I see it is like they're all
gonna [ __ ] us which one is probably
gonna [ __ ] us in a way that won't hurt
us so hard a little less harder or I get
a little benefit I just want a little
bit Yeah I want to come a little bit
just a little bit because if you elect
whether it's a Dem democrat or a
republican right if you do if you if you
elect an old school politician they play
the game where the banks the military
industrial complex old media they have
their own network of boys they're gonna
go into another War a lot of American
lives are gonna go get lost and die for
their for their gain right at least with
a new person coming along you don't know
what their special interests are so it
might be also be the war machine but it
might not be so then if you try someone
else that maybe their special interest
is just Silicon Valley and they have no
interest in like you know making money
with the military so them and it's every
group every Camp is different they use
their power position to basically milk
the system with them and their team yeah
so I just want the team to have a
special interest in something that
doesn't hurt a lot of people and for me
Trump was real estate and there they did
really well with real state right they
put in great laws for the rest of us we
did really well with real estate during
that time but there were no Wars it he
didn't start any new Wars none of that
stuff and that's my thing is like let's
find an evil that isn't so evil so you
bring in someone that maybe starts a ton
of [ __ ] Wars it's dangerous yeah for
us and the public but then he well I
disagree because he might forgive
student loans awake he might not he's
not going he's going to pull that back
because now it's post-election time and
they just had a court say that that's
unconstitutional and so now they're
going to give up on that and so you guys
all got God and that's what happens
every [ __ ] time anytime something
could happen that could help people
again not to be too cynical but this
always happens it gets rolled back like
Obamacare was a big gimme for insurance
companies insurance companies wrote the
Bill they wrote it and that's why the
insurance companies benefited and that's
why all Health Care spiked everywhere
and that's why everyone hates our health
care System even more somehow yeah and
I'm not saying oh my God it was so great
before no it sucked ass before it sucks
even more ass now I think what people
fail to realize is the game isn't being
played for us it's being played it's for
them or like let's say if you look at
the hierarchy right of who actually runs
this country the corporations in the
campaign funders corporatists and in the
groups like the special interest groups
that give campaign funding they're the
ones that are trying to place in laws
that work for their team and their
industry
all of us that work for them or just
maybe small business or whatever we're
not even in that same group so they win
our votes but all the plays are
happening here that benefit them but
they're counting on us fighting each
other the whole time and not even
noticing them and that's how the game's
been played for like my entire life and
didn't we keep saying like hey once
Trump is gone and there's a new
president there's going to be a new war
a new [ __ ] War we said this yeah
years ago years ago and then they're
like no you don't understand it's a new
era look you Ukraine happened like that
always [ __ ] happens because the same
Playbook is always repeated but we look
it's as fun as it is to say yeah good
boy give Trump a gold star he didn't
start a new war he continued the old
Wars he didn't ending he didn't end it
he didn't yeah he was bombing the [ __ ]
out of the Middle East too just like
Obama did just like [ __ ] Bush did
beforehand and you know Everyone likes
to pretend like oh my God Bush was this
new warmonger it was just a continuation
of what we're already doing yeah like
George H.W was talking about you know
the New World Order the whole time and
that was all part of the project for New
American Century which was the Dick
Cheney Outlet like and that was like hey
we need to like basically redefine the
Middle East by taking it the [ __ ] over
classic American hegemony where we just
take control places and we use excuses
like democracy and freedom yeah I'm just
gonna make them our own corporate
corporatist interests put a KFC into
McDonald's in there collect a sick ass
check back at home and we'll figure it
out later and that's what we do every
[ __ ] time and it's amazing how people
fall for it and yeah God bless Ronald
Reagan the president I was born he was
you know in my little baby book says
you're born in the oregano
Administration that guy was like giving
money the contras they were [ __ ]
running guns like they were working all
kinds of Corporations they started the
CIA started the crack epidemic and the
black neighborhood exactly and it's and
it's all like God damn I love my [ __ ]
president I'm is my president and people
say like oh you know the Republicans
with uh George H.W bush he started the
war and it's like no like actually
Clinton was already bombing out uh
Taliban so and then before that
George senior started invading Iraq so
it's like dude the game's been being
played like way back then they have like
bush
it was only Bush and like he [ __ ] it
all up oh no Clinton said he changed the
policy of uh the United States towards
Iraq to one of regime change we need to
change regime in Iraq because Saddam is
a bad player because Saddam is not
playing the game to our terms that's
what happened in Libya with Gaddafi
that's what happens anytime you ever
oppose accepting our monetary system yep
as yours you don't want to play the
Petro dollar game guess what dude we're
gonna come for you dude and we're gonna
rape your guy with a knife in the street
which is what they did to Gaddafi it's
crazy
so Eisenhower had this pretty famous
speech after World War II or he was
talking about the military-industrial
complex it was the very first time that
publicly a president even talked about
the existence of the military industrial
complex and he was talking about there
are secret societies basically he didn't
say that word for word but he said there
are secret groups within that is the
biggest threat to America beware the
influence how's Kennedy right no Dwight
well no he talked about secret societies
Kennedy and yes yeah Dwight Eisenhower
talked about beware the influences with
Assad or unsought by The American or by
the military industrial complex so
they're both talking about the same
thing yeah and basically they probably
saw that they're like as a president
they're like I can't even do my job
because this is just baked into the
system now and this is the biggest
threat to the American people and then
so after that I think like you know it's
just a game like people like the new
president but the president really
doesn't have as much power as these
groups have been in power for for a very
very long time there's not a president
that I like my favorite thing though is
that I look at memes and they go
remember when Obama like only his only
Scandal was a tan suit I'm like yeah
dude cool my brother was in the Drone
program then and like trust me a dancing
if you think it was a tan suit you're
[ __ ] nuts they used to bomb they
would bomb families in vans in houses in
hospitals they would kill civilians with
drones and then they would just
reclassify them as enemy combatants
which is why surgeons yeah yeah and you
and you could see the statistics during
the Obama Administration they just
started cooking the books and saying
like oh we're auditing ourselves don't
worry
they would just reassess
these accidents right and then basically
making excuses for why they're doing
[ __ ] up things in the Middle East I
wonder why they hate us you know it's so
funny like like but they would
reclassify all these these innocent
people dying and then they're wondering
why we're getting more terrorists all
the time yeah gee I wonder why and and
how can you even call them terrorists
when when they see the American flag
they see something different than Wheels
100 and and that's a scary reality
coming from a military family like you
have to you look yourself in the mirror
at some point wow okay that was great
I could watch you guys talk politics all
day is it really politics though we
really don't know what we're talking
about I'm drunk